what kind of impact do you expect the  measles outbreak that took place in  December really to have on your theme  park business in California over the  spring and summer if any well clearly  there's been a lot of attention about  measles and we do know that some people  who visited disneyland in anaheim hat  basil came down with the measles we  obviously take that very seriously but  we have not discerned any real impact  from that to date in fact if you look at  our business in this quarter not the  quarter that we just announced but in  this quarter we're running ahead of last  year in terms of attendance and in terms  of advance bookings so we conclude that  there's really no impact from this